I want to talk to you guys about this uh
new cartoon coming out in a couple hours
actually it's called has been hotel and
I'm seeing some uh uh outrage over it
because it is as some describe well the
veneration of demons so you have this uh
this story uh actually I I'll play I'll
play the trailer for you guys the first
thing I want to say is I'm not acting
like this's this big outrage campaign
against it there's just I see people
posting these things uh on on Twitter
talking about how it makes Lucifer to be
the good guy it eliminates the concept
of God it is a fictional show about
demons in hell that are being killed by
Heaven because Heaven's actually the bad
guys who want social order and in hell
they're trying to convince bad people to
repent so they can get let back into
heaven I don't see it as inherently like
good or bad but there is a question
around producing content that is popular
winning a culture war and uh Biblical
teaching so let me just play this for
you and then then I'll want get your
guys thoughts on it once upon a time
there was a glowing City protected by
Golden in Gates known as Heaven it was
ruled by beings of pure light angels
that worshiped good and shielded all
from Evil Lucifer was one of these
angels He was a dreamer with Fantastical
ideas for all of creation but he was
seen as a troublemaker by the Elders of
Heaven for they felt his way of thinking
was dangerous to the order of their
world so he watched as the Angels began
to expand the universe in their ways
from the Dust of Earth they created Adam
and Lilith equals as the first of
mankind but despite this Adam demanded
control and Lilith refused to submit to
his will she fled the garden drawn in by
her Fierce Independence Lucifer found
her and the two rebellious dreamers fell
deeply in
love wiing wish to share the magic of
Free Will with Humanity offering the
fruit of knowledge to Adam's new bride
Eve who gladly accepted did but this
gift came with a curse for with this
single act of Disobedience evil finally
found its way into Earth with it a new
Realm of Darkness and sin and the order
Heaven had worked to maintain was
shattered as punishment for their
Reckless act Heaven cast Lucifer and his
love into the dark pit he had created
never allowing him to see the good that
came from Humanity only the cruel and
the wicked ashamed Lucifer lost his will
to dream but Lilith thrived empowering
demonkind with her voice and her songs
and as the numbers of mom when we need
her did its power threatened by this
Heaven made a truly heartless decision
that every year they would send down an
army an extermination to ensure hell and
its Sinners could never rise against
them but Lilith's hope remained and her
dream was passed down to to their
precious daughter the princess of
hell don't worry Mom I'll make you proud
so there's this uh it's it's a show on
YouTube there's another show that's
related to it super popular it's got uh
they get like tens of millions of views
but basically that what I'm seeing from
a lot of people they're commenting
saying that that the the propagandists I
don't think it's I don't like that look
Prime all they're saying like Amazon
Prime is doing this Amazon Prime has
sound of freedom on it and it's actively
promoting sound of Freedom I'll take it
it also is now launching this show I
think they saw a big audience they said
let's take it but the controversy arises
in that this show makes it out that uh
one that Lilith is real uh and you know
a lot of people again I'm not a bib
biblical scholar but people are like
that's blasphemy and that Lucifer is not
a bad guy but also people are saying
it's not even actual actually biblical
there is no God Heaven is evil Heaven
wants to just go and exterminate all
these people by sending soldiers down to
kill them and uh my my whole take on
this is I I think it's interesting
because if your concern is that major
media is funding massively shows that
corrupt Biblical teaching in some way
whether intentionally or otherwise the
answer is to build culture and counter
it by making your own content shows
cartoons or otherwise complain about
it's not going to solve anything but I'm
curious what you guys think if if if it
even matters it's got amazing production
value I will say that like it it looks
well drawn why were you wincing okay the
thing is it is it is s of interesting to
think of this as like a thought
experiment where someone was like I'm
going to tell you the story and then you
have to spin it so it's completely the
opposite of it like in that way it is
almost fascinating what they have done
yeah I mean I don't think it's that bad
of a thing to be honest with you I mean
I'm not a Satanist but it's just vice
versa it's just it's entertainment yeah
it's it's like what if God was evil or
from the from a bad guy perspective
there's video games that let us see from
the bad guy perspective yeah I don't
like the idea of like restricting art I
think that you have to have like
countercultural ideas and this would be
countercultural cuz like chran bels but
like the thing that is like when I'm
looking at it I'm like did you did you
who wrote this like did you grow up in a
church and learn the story and then you
like but I have decided to change it or
are you someone who doesn't understand
like the story of Adam and Eve and
everything and you have been like well
Adam actually seems like a really
oppressive guy and he wouldn't let eat
from the apple and that's very rude well
you saw like in the beginning it's like
lith would not submit to ad to the man
she was fiercely independent she's such
a feminist girl boss then she the silly
trickster Satan who's just hanging out
or whatever his name is you know like
like it's it is like I'm wincing because
it's my brain being like this is very
weird but on the other hand like whoever
wrote this should go work for some top
government PR spin room because they
really can be
like funny about it someone commented
that it's lowkey based because it has
all the gay people in hell and I was
like that's actually should be rather
offensive to them but the issue is
because the people behind it are are I I
my understanding is they're like woke
they created a bunch of characters that
you know are like them and so all the
people that are in hell are leftists
which I'm sure that comes from like them
being like Oh everyone else says I'm
going to hell because of whatever
however I live my life or whatever no I
think it's more like the characters we
make need to be diverse so let's make
all of our characters diverse and it's
like you just put a bunch of woke
leftists in Hell well isn't that isn't
that where they out they'd probably be
happier there you know that's what
they're saying they're like Heaven's a
bad place diversity the term diversity
has changed too cuz now diversity pretty
much means insert different type of like
lgbtq in the past it used to be like
bring an Indian here bring a Asian right
here bring a black right here it's
completely different now what well
Asians Asians are no longer considered
diverse according to most government
contracts that require quotas what for
real yeah are you serious yeah yeah
Asians east east Asians as well as South
Asians I know in New York in the um
architecture and engineering contracts
they have quota systems for minorities
but quota system there's no quota for
Asians because they are over represented
in those fields it doesn't count anymore
it was the Asian student groups that
brought initially brought the admissions
lawsuit Supreme Court this is why I no
longer identify as Asian I'm actually
Hispanic because I think that's SM
Hispanic means speak Spanish I'm Native
American and so because me and Elizabeth
Warren same amount but but so so no no
check this out when you are filling out
a form and it says Caucasian Hispanic
African-American whatever Hispanic means
speak Spanish yeah it does not mean you
are from Latin America or whatever it
could mean that M but it literally means
Spanish speaking that's why they say
there's white hispanic too bad I so I'm
just gonna be like I speak Spanish uh it
uh how do I say El Sombrero D esta la
bibla I was uh dog sitting for Dane our
our marketing guy when he went on his
honeymoon and he and his wife have two
dogs and they both speak Spanish at home
and so they came to my house and like
one is calm and one is is really scared
and my roommate and I were trying to
figure out like how to like talk to them
we're like it's okay you know different
and then it occurred to us that like
these dogs only speak Spanish and we
were saying like I can't say anything I
said like bibla but she said like you're
you're Bonita and one of the dogs like
turned around and looked at her like yes
I am like they had no idea what we're
talking about until we started speaking
Spanish I speak Spanish
AA so Candace said that means outside I
guess she she didn't know about the
melee meme but uh it means out like it
could it's a verb too like get out and
uh it's always weird when I hear people
tell tell me this cuz I went to Spain
during the the uh uh the M something
protest M24 whatever protests and the
cops this I I love this in uh France no
wait wait we'll start with America in
America the SWAT police uh the the the
right cops they all hold their trunch
they stand in line and they go like this
as they move forward and they yell move
move in uh France and in Canada you know
what they say what bouge o yeah which
means move right but you are bougie you
out here prot in Spain you know what
they say
AA they yell AA as they're pushing
people out like get out and so when I
was in Spain hearing them yell that I
was like I kind of understand what
they're saying they're saying like get
out move go away or whatever and then my
friends were saying they're saying out
out out and uh then I had people tell me
that it means outside and I guess it's
like for people who only just speak a
little bit of Spanish they like that
means outside why are you saying that
and I'm like Javier mle was yelling aera
as he was ripping the things down and uh
you know Dane messaged me and he was
like it means like get out or outside as
well Dane fact Tex Spanish all the time
so I speak Spanish now that means I'm
Hispanic and I am no longer I I tweeted
identify as Asian because uh there were
these leftists arguing that I don't
qualify as mixed race unless I assert
that I identify as such that the actual
DNA within my body and the race of my
mother is meaningless and the only thing
that matters is I choose to identify as
such and I'm like really because
identity is a political designation it's
not identity isn't isn't anything about
your me you identify as Asian I'm
totally Asian what are you kidding me
you're out of your mind well I'm
Hispanic from now on because it means
speak Spanish take that Dane thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday Frid at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net